was geht hier sei max und herzlich
willkommen so wahrscheinlich letzten
nero folge in gammel look wir haben's
letzte folge in einem extrem nächsten
moment ausgeloggt und sind jetzt wieder
auf dem server wir befinden uns am
abgang zum zum leser teil des dungeons
in dem wir uns befinden
die haben wir so ultra schnell geklärt
letzte folge den dungeon also einfach
runter in die letzten beiden etagen
wohnt in die letzten beiden etagen ganz
einfach und dann alles ausgecheckt so
wir werden da auf jeden fall auch runter
gehen ganz bald
aber ich muss erst mal gucken dass ich
hier die spanne ausfindig machen hätte
schon mal vorsichtig case bei dass wir
nicht vergiftet werden eschborner
ausfindig gemacht sind hier glaube ich
immer nur 21 sind damage ja das ist sehr
gut auf jeden fall so zu essen
für essen ist ist als ich das hier auch
schon mal als gelohnt kann man sagen
fasst aber hier die drops was man hier
so rauskriegt leute lässt stark zu
wünschen übrig ich bin ja nach wie vor
hätte ich gerne eine gas trainer glück
gehabt noch mal ja nochmal glück gehabt
kann man so sagen
da und nicht wieder der leser teil so
hier das gucke ich mir auch ganz kurz an
was sie in den kisten drin ist gebt mir
meine gas träne leute was anderes wäre
ich nicht komm schon kein glück aber ich
habe sowieso das gefühl wenn man sucht
dann findet man nicht wird er
wahrscheinlich so ein passendes sprich
sprichwort dafür irgendwie wer sucht der
findet nicht oder so
so drei diaz ja sage ich nicht nein zu
dem tag wollte ich eigentlich nicht
loswerden
ok also die drobs werden schon auf jeden
fall sehr vernünftig jetzt die man hier
so februar ich dreh mich jetzt und in
klarer geschossen
die drobs lernt schon sehr vernünftig
die man hier findet mittlerweile dass
der typische sound ist so ich alles
ausgeleuchtet ja sagt mir dass hier noch
ins porno es noch eine kiste aber auch
hier kein glück wie das jetzt gerade auf
den ersten blick außer mining fertig
kann ich eigentlich drauf scheißen ganz
ehrlich gesagt vielleicht ist das
vernünftig jetzt für unten im netter
teil dass ich nicht brennen kann
vielleicht lohnt sich das nicht zu mir
die ihr ein halter was sich hier hat als
übersehen hätte gut dass hier mal
zurückgekommen bin ich dann für den
zombie auf jeden fall dass er gespannt
ist aber nach wie vor nichts was das was
ich so wirklich gerne hätte so deshalb
denke jetzt mal gehe ich einfach ab
runter in den usa teil
oma die dinger sind echt heftig ich weiß
nicht ich habe bestimmt auch andere
schon john die net gekläert und ihr habt
das habt es schon gesehen weist es so
gefährlich
genau da wollt ihr auch noch mal
reinschauen jetzt dem breitet die ändern
wollte ich ein paar von ihnen töten
damit ich mir dann später ausleuchten
will nicht dass ich dann später so
stirbt mit den ende perlen mein portal
weiter bauen kann das heißt weiter
worden dass sie überhaupt ein portal
bauen kann
darauf habe ich nämlich extrem bocchetta
ceo s bahn noch also es ist nicht so
sehr ausgeleuchtet sie auch fast kaum
ausgeleuchtet aber ich brauche auf jeden
fall ich glaube sie benennt appellen für
meinen plan mit dem wir uns dann über
meine blut magie in andere städte
teleportieren werden
das ist ziemlich episch
so aber ich möchte jetzt auch die ganze
folge nicht hier verbringen ich glaube
dafür um noch ein bisschen rum
aber ich muss hier in der nähe bleiben
dass die ende märz bonn
normalerweise freust du dich wenn die
features freuen freust dich zeigt
normalerweise nervig wenn die den
transport jetzt musst du hier abwarten
und abwarten aber ändern mainz bonn ja
gar nicht bevorzugt im dunkeln soweit
ich weiß
ich mach dir mal die lichtquelle ein
paar meter hinweg und das spornt auch
schon wieder der nächste die nächsten
zwei sehr gut
ich glaube der einsatz über irgendwelche
items gewirkt damit die goldlose okay
aber untypisch das intermezzo das
treffen finde ich irgendwie kerbel spawn
geht gerade schon gut ab ich hab
trotzdem erst zwei ende perlen und wenn
ich erst mal ganz kurz anschauen
zur telefonischen fokus was der tele
pauser kostet insgesamt drei weil das ja
auch noch eines sagen ich war
tatsächlich sieben länder perlen
insgesamt und es wäre schon echt killer
wenn wir jetzt alle kriegen würden nicht
mein lieber jetzt ein paar sekunden
damit zubringen geändert herren zu
besorgen
als dann später in der in der open world
rumzulaufen wo man halt nicht das glück
hat und den luxus hat in spa vor sich zu
haben dann dort die viecher zu holen
finde ich schon erheblich besser aber
ich kann ja schon mal so allmählich hier
runter gehen
drei stück das ist ja der wahnsinn drei
einer vereinbaren ich freue mich hier
noch was den fall extrem untypisches
verhalten für einen minecraft spieler
aber so ist der kollege hin
wieso können dies über becks worten bis
doch nur drei hoher raum aber die machen
schon schon gute damit aber halt einfach
also nicht genug für
das reduziere noch schönes gejobbt
shining powers ton klingt es wird etwas
drauf gleich mal ein genie items ok eine
einzige ein appell noch und dann ist es
erstmal geschafft hier so scheinen
paston shining paston shining futurezone
verrät zu mir zumindest nichts was man
mit den dingen anfangen kann
zunächst ist es das nächste center
männer gespannt ist ein bisschen dunkel
gerade auch für mich also wundert euch
nicht als erster ein bisschen wenig seht
aber hoffentlich toppen die kollegen ja
noch eine weitere länder werden an
welchen wirklich sehr verbunden und
jetzt haben wir sieben ender perlen
das läuft echt wie geschmiert gerade ich
wäre fast ein bisschen überrascht wenn
wir nicht noch irgendwie doof städten
führen
es würde eigentlich nicht zu unserem
glück hier in dem projekt passen
lighthouse und dort oben wird es nacht
und ich hoffe mal dass sie auch direkt
den raum hier finde ich ist der abgang
ich hoffe dass sie direkt im rahmen
finden mit dem wir dann in den ja in den
and part von dem von der ganzen
geschichte hier kommt vom ganzen dungeon
geld anstellt ja unten
ein netter teil wo sich insgesamt vier
kisten befinden und profis noch zwei
frauen also ich glaube acht sportler
sind insgesamt mit dem man sich
rumschlagen darf aber es lohnt sich
so viel kann ich euch sagen so und ich
glaube in richtung von irgendeiner wand
findet man das ding also hinter
irgendeiner wand hier verbirgt sich
meines wissens
der marke cube interessant das wollte
ich nur mal ganz kurz schließen ja
hinter irgendeiner verwandt verbirgt
sich meines wissens der der nächste
abgang in diesem besagten gefährlichen
raum
das sieht eigentlich verdächtig aus hier
irgendwo ist das definitiv wichtig sind
einfach mal schnell offline also vom
server herunter und guckt danach ob das
finde so rüstung und schwert sind noch
zu gebrauchen
ich hatte am anfang ein bisschen schiss
dass das vielleicht ein bisschen sehr
wenig haltbarkeit ist die das schwert
hatte zumindest okay vielleicht hat mir
das einfach früher machen sollen einmal
drauf los ziehen bisschen risiko weil
der dadurch das risiko eingegangen sind
ich habe diesen links als indikator
gekommen den lehnt den oxidieren dabei
war das einfach nur wegen dem wasser was
da gerade um runter gekommen war
sowohl sind die fackel nicht mehr machen
aber blind wenn ich mir das so anschaue
hier irgendwo ist das verdammt nochmal
irgendwo ist dieser raum
das zumindest war vielleicht vielleicht
gibt es auch mehrere von diesen toten
enden irgendwie von der von dem
niedergang dass sie zur verdächtige aus
so kann man mal hoch aber es würde mich
wundern wenn das über meer ist wo armut
ist zum ersten mal vertritt hatte
gefragt wäre das alles hat wenn er wenn
er gute das braucht dann nehme ich das
auf jeden fall mal mit weil patrick hat
schon so viel für uns getan dass ich ihm
auf jeden fall den gefallen tue hier so
wenn es das schon direkt so an lacht vor
unserer nase zeigen wir doch nicht nein
so ok soll ich gucke mir zurück es
wundert mich ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
das dass wir den raum nicht direkt
gefunden haben
aber ach so heißt es da ist das ding
gibt hier noch weitere abgänge und das
hier oben war glaube ich alles bei
dieser krippe explosion geplatzt
tun wir das hier mal da hin wo wir haben
auch zehn minuten zeit leute auf jeden
fall noch jede menge um hier dinge zu
schaffen so auf jeden fall armut ist für
patrick der gute mann hat es verdient so
durch hier
vor sponti einfach was ja also wir
müssen ein bisschen hier absuchen
einfach über ein paar fackeln platzieren
dass wir uns zurechtfinden
also hinter so einem rahmen was
definitiv nicht neue direktive hätte das
früher gemacht
es ist gerade richtig wer die recht so
das gefühl dass wir ein bisschen haken
bei nero geht jetzt hab ich auch
aufgenommen
ein bisschen hecken sind die fackeln ist
leer
ein paar kann ich mir auf jeden fall
noch machen was das hat aber nervig sind
kriegt so viel schicken sei inventar und
so einbeck wenn ich mir definitiv auch
noch mal vorknöpfen
kers ist unmöglich jeder drop einfach so
ein tunnel runter so jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt das schlimmste was man finden
kann so ein tunnel
den habe ich der gartner
platzierungsspanne oder so die armut ist
spitzhacke hält jede menge aus schon
relativ lange zumindest okay
die spanner abbauen und den skeletten
bisschen ignorieren nicht das ist sie
ganz neues bahn
knochen sind der servicemann beider tod
ausleuchten zerstören auch schon wieder
so ein totes ende hier
ich hoffe einfach dass ich den den
rahmen noch finde
sonst mache ich mich einfach schlau vor
der nächsten folge die ich aufnehme wo
die dinger zu finden sind
also das war auch schon wieder ein totes
ende hier da drüben war ich auch schon
drin was machen wir den sound hier für
sein eis wenn der kollege einfach
verbrennen möchte bietet ihnen das zu
tun
ein bug ein gast lieber kein um genau zu
sein
das wrack der hat mir nur diesen ekligen
komischen fälle gegeben mich tatsächlich
ein bisschen verwirrt damit wissen wir
essen ja sehr schön
die dinge haben auf jeden fall eine
chance weit rüstung zu droppen oder
alten volt banner ist mir das jetzt in
den slot wert ob ich so was auf jeden
fall iraner ist aufgehoben
ich hatte sogar anscheinend doch sowieso
in der tat frei gehabt und hier gehts
darunter ok wo leute wir sind jetzt im
gefährlichsten raum denen so ein dungeon
zu bieten hat es geht jetzt erstmal alle
alles vorne abzubauen alles zu klären
und dann kriegen wir den in der folge
noch erledigt höchstwahrscheinlich
vielleicht haben wir glück snatchers
netter star
hey was sind wir halt bitte netter stern
gedroppt wenn man sage ich nicht nein
dazu lego city store und wünsche seien
er ist halt irgendwie so ein klima
sofort es nimmt hier recht überhand
langsam mit mit dem mit dem spot zeigt
nächstes borner ist kaputt und ich
aufgeregt gerade aber das merkte
wahrscheinlich selbst kommt er kommt her
ja es ist nicht so wirklich kritischen
haben wir kassieren hier jede menge hits
und die sind griffig für unsere rüstung
viele können gar nicht gut sein aber sie
hält noch so einiges aus umfassend und
das lag vor allem mit den ganzen welt
ist dass davon auch nicht
vernachlässigen das könnte auch
gefährlich sein dass sie einfach die
ganze zu leicht so ausleuchten stirbt
schon ausgeleuchtet ich gucke mir das
alles gleich in ruhe an
erstmal will ich hier alles gesichert
wissen
vor allen dingen von diesen
schrecklichen spinnen sie sind die
nerven schächter am allermeisten der
platten schere in der hand die die
sex-party sharin bleibe ich sogar mit
butter skelette nur das skelett leute
ryan die wand
boa war das knapp leute war das gerade
knapp vor ich bin einfach nur froh dass
ich überlebt haben ich bin happy gerade
bei ich ich gehe jetzt erstmal in ruhe
den defekt von mining fertig sonst dann
klopfe ich mir den dienst rang vier
trank rein hab ich glaube das bedeutet
einfach abbau lähmung
das würde bedeuten dass wir die sportler
nicht geklärt bekommen tut mir leid dass
ich das gerade nebenbei google aber
mining für tig müsste wir können auch
einfach umstellen aber manni fatyka
probleme richtig war hier schon gedacht
aber das wird es nicht so unser problem
werden
erst mal schön voll regenerieren ableben
und jan ein solches in kauf nehmen das
hebt die große frage
john brennan what the [ __ ]
ich mache mir alles ein bisschen angst
hier
so dass hier kann raus dass ihr kann her
das kann rein das kann rein so die viele
machen wir da angst mit ihrem ich lasse
einfach plötzlich max brennen so jeder
kommt mit baby zombies seien die
wenigsten mal das was jetzt vor der tür
ab geht weil es ist jede menge wie ihr
seht okay wir sind eigentlich schon
wieder voll gerecht ist kann niemand
rein das war natürlich nicht so genau
weg damit
insbesondere jetzt vor wir ausnahmsweise
mal genug haben von einem dass sie zu
wertvoll aus dieser shining stone möchte
eigentlich auch ungern wegwerfen so
leute wie ich muss erst mal ganz kurz
wirklich überlegen mache ich das ist es
mir wert dass ich deshalb locker klären
dass ich die alle töten kann dass ich
diesen komischen trank trinke ganz
ehrlich diese ganzen weile mixas die die
hier am start sind wir alle nicht so
übermäßig geheuer und lieb so czech
nächste check nächste das war das lager
dinge leute es ist so fucking intense
hier so und ich habe lieber wieder ab
aber ich habe kein wasser mehr das habe
ich auch nicht vergessen
kein wasser mehr ist nicht schön
die park kriege ich auf jeden fall
ich glaub ja ich nehme ich nehme es
diese fucking meinung fertig in kauf und
schaue mir dafür die streng was ich
sonst alles kriege jetzt habe ich mal
fackeln doch 1 2 habe ich noch ja ich
nehme das jetzt alles in kauf es mir
egal so streng habe ich rund
feuer resistenz so wenn wir jetzt
irgendwas noch gefährlich werden kann
dann weiß ich auch nicht was so zack
zack
woran hätte alle one hit kommt dann
einfach so also wahrscheinlich meine
kritik 4 kann ich echt die sportler
nicht abbauen
ich teste das ganz normal noch mal ganz
kurz aus mitgas trainer sehr schön in
texas tischdecken sehr gut das sind wir
hier schön ist drin jetzt gerne anders
gemacht wirklich ist ja ich hätte gern
ich hatte ganz gerne dass das ganze
anders angegangen und hätte erst die
s-bahn abbaut und dann ganz schön in
ruhe alles hier gelautet
ok also ich muss sagen so ganz unruhig
ist das jetzt auch nicht wie ich das
hier gerade mache dann an weder und
nochmal die lava weg so ganz unrecht ist
das auch nicht aber es wäre schon
deutlich entspannter anders anderweitig
gewesen eine karotte rockt hier sehr
schön zum anbauen karotten finde ich
eigentlich immer ganz gut
deshalb werde ich auch viel flair ich
beschäftige ich mich überhaupt nicht
damit und ich hoffe ich habe jetzt
niemanden damit er bewusst dass ich
diesen job dropped haare
was soll das denn
was war das denn hier ok es wird mir
gerade ein bisschen bisschen stressig
land ist hier mal verdammt noch mal wir
haben eigentlich alles was wir wollten
warum mache ich hier noch weiter leute
gute frage die folge sind hier auch zu
ende
ich will mich jetzt hier ausloggen ich
überlege noch ob ich nächste folge noch
weiter den dungeon informel täter das
war das problem die stärke war vorbei
auf mich nicht folgen dungeon auch
weiter vornehmen
das war erstmal von heute außer
durchgefallen und bis zum nächsten mal